MARKUS KLUTE:
Welcome back to 871.
So in this section of our
discussion of instrumentation,
we talk about
accelerators, and I'll
do this in a little bit of
an historic way showing you
some of the developments over
the last up to 100 years.
We use electromagnetic
fields in order
to accelerate charged particles,
and so the developments
in electromagnetic and
understanding electromagnetism
led to then the
technical developments
or the technological
development of accelerators
and the availability
of devices, which
can be used in order to
accelerate or modify particles.
And so this goes back
to Maxwell and Hertz
discovering
electromagnetic waves
towards JJ Thomson,
who was able to use
cathode rays and the
classical Lorentz force
in order to understand the
electromagnetic fields.
If we study particle
accelerators,
we can see three
different historic lines--
direct voltage accelerators,
resonant accelerators,
and transformer
accelerators, and we
go through those three
different subjects one by one.
The energy limits
of our accelerators,
they are typically given by
the maximum possible voltage
available.
When you think about
accelerators used for colliding
beams, it's not just the energy
which is the limiting factor,
but you also need a
sufficient number of particles
to be accelerated and
brought to collisions.
And those particles need
to be in some sort of beam,
which is narrow such that
collisions are possible.
Requirements change
depending on whether or not
you have colliding beams or
fixed target experiments,
whether or not
you actually study
lepton collisions,
or hadron collisions,
whether or not you're
using secondary particles
as the means of what you're
going to learn from this.
But the concepts are
very comparable across
individual fields of study.
So let's start with
the van der Meer--
Van de Graaff accelerator.
So you basically have to be
able to create large voltages,
and for the Van de
Graaff accelerator,
it's been doing this,
creating this large voltage,
by just moving particles from
on one level-- separating
particles to create
this large voltage.
You can typically get up to
megavolts and tens of megavolts
of voltages, but you
need to make sure
that you don't enter a
breakdown kind of regime.
And so it depends on what
kind of insulating materials
you use.
If you are using insulating
gas under certain environmental
conditions, you get up to
17.5 megavolts, which then can
be used in order to accelerate.
We can use the fact that you can
use the electric fields twice
in the tandem
accelerators by changing
the direction of the voltage.
Large potential differences
have been field of studies
in the 1920s and
'30s, and one not so--
and it's just noteworthy that
this is a dangerous field.
So Brasch and Lange,
they use potential
from lightning in
the Swiss Alps,
but this was fatal for Lange,
who was electrocuted fatally
by a lightning strike.
So then you need to
think about how can you
make large voltages
available, and how can you
make them available
for acceleration?
Cockcroft-Walton
accelerators use a sequence
of a cascade generator in order
to reuse the voltage in order
to create a larger
potential for acceleration.
The max generator is very--
conceptually is
very, very similar.
Those are still
used today, so we
know why those developments
are 80 or 90 years old.
If you go to a Physics
Today article from 2003,
you see that a
machine like this is
being used in order to create an
initial confinement for fusion
reactors, and the total
power is rather fascinating.
It's four terabytes, which can
be released in 100 nanoseconds
from a larger number of
those Marx generators.
In modern particle
physics accelerators,
we use resonant
acceleration quite a lot,
and the idea is really like
it's shown in this picture
here, that the
charged particles,
they're kind of being
accelerated on a wave.
So basically, they're surfing
on electromagnetic waves.
And this can be seen here.
You just place them
correctly in your waveform
on a specific
point, and then they
can be accelerated
over some distance.
So the key point
here is that you
have a proper or correct phase
relation to the accelerating
voltage, and the set
up can be varying.
And historically,
there's various attempts
to do this in an optimal way.
The first one is
the cyclotron, which
has a static magnetic
field, and in each turn,
your particles are
being injected,
and then in each
turn, your particle's
getting a kick here
and a kick here.
And because their
velocity is increasing,
the radius in this
fixed magnetic field
is increasing as well.
So after some time, the
particle is accelerated
and leaves the cyclotron
as a specific velocity.
Focusing here is important.
You don't want to
just inject particles
and then they spray all over the
place, an accelerator's focus
and having the right
optics for the particle is
a key part of the work needed.
There's a number of techniques.
I don't want to go
into too much detail,
but what you typically
see is if you compress
the beam in one
direction, it decomposes
in the other direction.
And so quadruple magnets
can be used in order
to get them focusing, and
use fringe field and edge
field in order to make
sure that the beam itself
stays in a compact form.
You can also do techniques
where you have initial focusing
in one direction and then
in the other direction,
so the result can
be made smaller.
Accelerators are not
just important today
in particle physics, but
they have specifically
found their place in
medical applications,
in tumor therapy specifically.
And the history
here is very long.
You see those initial
ideas or methods
where neutrons are used--
[INAUDIBLE] neutrons are used
in order to treat tumors.
We haven't discussed this
in nuclear physics too much,
but when you use ions
as a radiation form,
you can really pinpoint
where energy is deposited.
The so-called Bragg
peak is used in order
to precisely figure in
a three-dimensional way
where the energy of the
ions is being deposited.
This is in contrast to radiation
therapy with photons, which
just basically spray a larger
part of the light material
and just destroy
the cancerous cells
but also the ones which
are still healthy.
Any given large
hospital nowadays
has a small accelerator, and so
there's thousands and thousands
of those available.
And the work and the maintenance
of those is [INAUDIBLE]..
But continuing the discussion
of accelerator concepts,
these kind of
racetrack accelerators
are quite interesting.
You basically have
a couple of fixed--
you have your particles
being injected,
and it's getting,
like in the cyclotron,
larger and larger kicks,
and then, at some point,
can be injected in
order to do experiments.
Again, this is
not the technology
which is not new anymore.
MAMI is an accelerator at the
University of Mainz, and it's--
the next generation is
using-- the next generation
of accelerators at this facility
is using a similar technology.
The question is what
kind of conditions
you have to fulfill in order
to keep the particles in place,
and here because the particle
moves along, it, in each turn,
takes more time in order
to make one circulation.
So what you want to make
sure is that your phase
and the acceleration
stays in sync,
so you want to make sure that
the particular event comes
around again, gets another kick,
and it's not deaccelerated.
And so that explains
why in those machines
the particles are bunched.
They come in little
blocks of particles
instead of just being a
continuous stream of particles,
and you can work out the
conditions necessary in order
to fulfill the requirement
that particles are
being continuously accelerated.
So then there's-- over
the history a number
of technologies which try to
make use of the fact that when
you accelerate, the velocity
of the particles increases,
and so initially, at a specific
time, with one sequence,
the particle gets a kick.
And then in the next
time, it's already faster.
It travels further, so you can--
[INAUDIBLE] a linear
accelerator structure,
so you just increase the length
of each accelerator structure
in order to make sure that
you, again, can give particles
the necessary kick.
Nowadays, they use cavities, and
we use superconducting cavities
in order to make them
energy efficient in order
to have large gradients.
The general idea is, again,
that you place your particle
in here, and you place
it such in your face
in your electromagnetic
field that it always
gets a kick instead of
being on the other side
and being deaccelerated.
Again, the Alvarez Linac
is a very similar concept,
so the advantage
here is that you only
have one power
input, which then you
couple and the walls of the
machine don't dissipate energy.
So then next, once you have an
accelerator structure in place,
you also want to make sure
that the structure itself
doesn't interfere with a beam,
that the power transfer is
as efficient as possible,
such that you can get more
for your buck.
All right, I mentioned
it a few times already,
the fact when you have
an electromagnetic wave
of this form and you
put your particle here,
the question is what happens
to these particles which
have a slightly higher energy
over these particle which
have a slightly lower energy?
And it turns out that
this kind of wave
has a self-focusing kind
of structure in a sense
that the particles were
a little bit behind, they
get a little bit larger kick.
Particles which are a
little bit in front,
they get a little
bit lower kick, which
means overall in energy
you focus your bunch.
In energy and space,
you focus the bunch.
You can go one step further
using RF quadrupoles.
Again, no details given here.
You use this unit in order
to further squeeze the beam
and reduce the footprint in
energy and space, the phase
space your particles
are occupying.
All right, the next level here
is then to use a betatron,
and the idea of the
betatron is that you change
the magnetic field as you go.
Instead of changing the
size of the structure,
you change the
magnetic field, so you
can use the same structure in
order to confine your beams.
And the next level to this
is that you don't just
use one magnet.
You use many magnets, and
this is done in synchrotrons,
modern synchrotrons.
So here, again, the large
line in history, but the point
is that when you use the
same orbit for the particles,
the way you accelerate
them, your magnet structures
can become much, much smaller.
So you have many small magnets
instead of one large magnet,
and only one or few accelerator
sections are needed.
So the particle passes by
here as being accelerated,
and then you have magnets,
of course, a link, the ring,
which are able to change
their field strength.
Again, if you have
constant field strength,
the radius changes, but if
you're modifying the field
strength accordingly to
the speed of the particle,
you can keep particles in
the same circular structure.
More words on the
focusing, again,
if you space a magnet such that
there's gradient in the fields
between--
depending on the position,
you can use that fact
in order to have particles
which are further out being
bent more inwards.
Particles which are further
inwards, bend more outwards.
This is called
refocusing, and you
can do this not just
once, but twice,
by changing the rotation.
And that's called
strong focusing.
Synchrotrons have limitations.
There's two which
are rather important.
The first one, the
radius of the synchrotron
is determined by the
momentum of the particle
and your magnetic field.
So at some point, you run
into technical limitations
on the magnetic field strength.
Modern superconducting
magnets, they
get up to in the order
of eight, nine tesla.
We are able to produce
accelerator-grade magnets up
to 14 tesla using
superconducting materials.
And so that then was a fixed
plot size of your tunnel
of your ring limits the amount
of momentum you can give
or energy you can
give to your particle.
And so for the LHC, we
accelerate protons up to 75 TV
in one beam, and we use the
magnetic field of 8.4 tesla.
So that's really the maximum the
machine can actually deliver,
and we haven't actually
demonstrated that we can get up
to this point.
Right now the center of mass,
the proton energy is 6.5 TV.
The previous concept
and construction
had started in Texas
in the United States
in the so-called SSC tunnel,
which was much, much larger,
had 87 kilometer tunnel.
The idea was to get
protons to center
at energies of 20 TV with
magnets of 6.8 tesla.
OK, this is one limitation,
the size of your tunnel.
The second one is when you
bend a charged particle
with the magnetic
field, it radiates,
and it radiates proportional
with the energy proportion
energy over mass to
the fourth power, which
means that you, at some point,
are limited by the power you
have to invest in the
beam to even just keep it
at a specific energy.
So this is e over m and
to the fourth power,
and this also gives you
a clue why we actually
accelerate protons in the
LHC and not electrons.
Electron mass is to low, and
this goes to the fourth power
here.
The [INAUDIBLE] of
electrons in the LHC tunnel
is just a limiting factor.
At some point, you don't have
enough power anymore in order
to give that to the
electrons or the particles
in order to accelerate that.
All right, so as I
was saying initially,
so you need focusing,
you need accelerating,
and you need all kinds
of additional components
to accelerate in order to
make good colliding beams,
and so it's much easier to just
dump a beam into a fixed target
and study what's coming out.
So colliding beams as a source
for input into particle physics
experiments came a
little bit later.
First concepts came to fruition
in Frascati in the 1960s,
and then we had SPEAR, a
electron positron collider.
It sent off mass energy of
four GeV, which then led
to the discovery of the J/Psi.
And then later, we had a five
GeV electron positron collider,
which was then
designed for eight GeV.
This then continued,
as you know,
to machines like
[INAUDIBLE],, which
had a center of mass
energy of up to 110 GeV.
And the LHC, the center of mass
energy of design of 14 GeV.
So the collider elements,
what do you need?
You need to inject
particles, and so you
have to have a
source of electrons
and a source of positrons.
Producing positrons is
just, technologically
in large numbers, much more
complicated than electrons.
Here you can-- in order to
get sufficient electrons,
you need to actually
produce them
with some kind of an
accelerator structure as well.
And so then they
need to be focused.
They need to be
cooled down in order
to have them as a beam being
injected in the structure.
So you've got-- you need
as additional components,
you need your RF generators.
You need magnets to bend
the beam in and out.
You need to have magnets in
order to bend the beam around,
so we need bending magnets.
You need focusing magnets
to keep the beam in orbit,
and then you want to--
before you bring them
to the collision, we want to
further focus the beam such
that you have more actual
particle collisions available.
And then you have
interaction points
where you will put your
particle for the experiment.
What's being done
here in this facility
is you inject, you
accelerate, and then you
store the beam to make
sure that you can fully
exploit the structure, so those
rings are called storage rings.
You avoid having a one kind
of shot kind of mentality
as you have, for example,
in linear machine.
Sometimes you do this
in separate rings.
in the same ring.
It depends on the
design of the machine.
The challenges are if you
have particles travel around
for hours that they shouldn't
interact with the gas,
for example, in your
accelerator structure.
[INAUDIBLE] by a very,
very good vacuum in order
to not lose the beam
as you have it stored.
The fields of your
accelerator structures
need to be very stable,
and that stable--
they have to be stable
for many, many hours.
That, for example,
there's some requirements
on your electric grid,
for example, such
that you have the stability
and voltage which don't end up
changing the actual field
strength of your magnet
as you go along.
Yeah, so again, I
already mentioned
this, the further development
of those machines.
In the '80s at CERN,
stochastic cooling
was used for the first time
in an antiproton machine,
and that machine
led to the discovery
of the w and the z bosons
and first really deep study
of the weak interaction at the
scale of the weak interaction.
At the TEVATRON
close to Chicago,
protons and antiprotons
were brought
to collision at the Fermilab at
the Fermi National Accelerator
Laboratory.
And the lab started in the
late 1980s in the same tunnel
as we find today the LHC.
At DESY in Hamburg, HERA was
used to collide electrons
with protons, and those results
led to our understanding
of the structure of the proton.
So you see that the reason
why I show you this history
here is that the progress
we did in particle physics
at the energy frontier, each
of the energy frontiers,
was very much tied to the
progress in accelerator
structures.
And rightfully so,
Simon van der Meer
recieved the Nobel Prize in
physics as an accelerator
physicist for the discovery
of the w and z boson.
He was working on
the machine and made
the machine possible
together with Carlo Rubbia.
And interesting, if you look
at the history of the particle
accelerators, it's interesting
to see how we may move
the energy frontier forward.
So what you see
in this plot here
is the available energy of the
machine, and what you see here
is line.
And this project is called
the Livingston Project.
See the logarithmic
scale, and you
saw that for a very long time
it was this logarithmic increase
in available energy.
So this line is
now turning over.
You're Already in 2020, and we
haven't made any progress here.
So focus here on this.
However, interesting
discussions on going somewhere--
going to high, going somewhere
here with the next machine
and being able to probe
further higher energies.
And the way this is proposed
for proton-proton collision
was just making a structure
similar to the LHC
but with a radius
about four times
larger, about 100 kilometers
compared to the 27
kilometers the LHC as today.
And so you can compare this with
the hadron machines, but also
the electron machines, and
also on the electron machines,
this trend is not as pronounced
as for the proton machines.
But basically, here, the
highest energy electron positron
collider [INAUDIBLE] has
just been decommissioned
at the end of the last
century, and we are thinking
about the next machine.
Sometimes you see those
acronyms as a linear machine,
international linear collider
or future circular collider.
It's electron and
positron collisions,
which would be
hosted in the very
same tunnel as this machine,
which is called FCCPP or HH.
HH was 100 kilometer
circumference.